pour mettre dans l'ambiance
j'ai ouvert mon strip tease espagnol aux
allures une merveille ce fait vous
regardez bien
rim est la bonne
seconde de button ces gants de moto ni
temps
ces bandes annonces
m
par les olé
voilà attendait l'ag de l'ordre tuez
vous faire profiter toute ma richesse
voilà alors voici l'histoire du célèbre
toréador temps d abord je me préparerai
parce que vous savez que les gitans à
nantes à visage toujours très très très
tourmentée et ceci grâce à la longueur
de leurs cheveux si si c'est alors
qu'ils ont toujours comme saint andré
les vergers me leny escudero vraiment ce
qu'on appelle le beatle du pauvre rim
est lamenté élimination de la pellicule
et qu'un million bonbons
attendez
oui où mais ouais mais on est tous
barrés hurlait tous made you less et à
la famille
camillo version française c'était un
grand tour d'espagne qui n'avait jamais
eu viendront à charmante revenus de
cerdagne un gentil toro doux comme un
agneau
pourtant malgré vincent de patients
n'auraient rond pouvez pas tuer la foule
à chaque fois il faisant confiance se
disaient ses preuves ailleurs
et ce cadeau était mis sous les yeux de
madrilènes
ces trois mêmes escamillo en effet
mureaux sans se perdre dans les détails
ce métier tout travail comme il savait
pas écartée el toro il évitait la foule
criait d'aspiration toro s'est levé sous
l'ovation escamillo j'étais le roi de la
corrida dans nice matin un camion
m
les ouïghours
ici
version française l'andalousie à la
cerdagne
chacun peut y voir et ce radio marte où
le public des villes et campagnes et
applaudi le grand torero
si bien qu'on organise ça sans peine à
madrid une grande euphorie d'un grand
escamillo aussi dans l'art est un
taureau furieux météo comme ça ah bon
bein empire khaled tous se tournent à
rennes
gentile toros en fuite façon les chaises
et tables puis par une lente ascension a
essayé encore d'influencer le jury
je vais me fâcher quand il arriva au
caleçon vers la fin ça devient un petit
peu olé olé quand ils règlent locales
sont les femmes crièrent d'applications
enlever le ballon allait permettre
d'irriguer ont enlevé leur enlever le
mélange pas le tolérer le ko est permis
thibault camus